I've seen a lot of pretty things I
catchers stunners everywhere but her my
god she's beautiful
[Music]
meet Horace just look at her she's a
little heavier to three and a half tons
but with almost 600 horsepower nice but
it's only there's no stress these girls
it's public knowledge that Russian arms
weapons are renowned worldwide with this
car our automobile industry rises to
stand shoulder to shoulder with our
defense industry I'm not throwing down a
challenge but this car proves that we
can make not only outstanding military
vehicles but also civilian good news
they let us go for a ride
unfortunately and I tried only as
passengers
[Music]
there's different versions of this car
that's the Cabriolet which we're in
which is specifically designed for the
parade than the 9th of May Victory Day
parade
then there's acid add-on which Vladimir
Putin has been seen a number of times
they're also making an off-road vehicle
an SUV potentially also available to the
public later on obviously this isn't an
economy car so the price is gonna be
pretty steep
[Music]
you